cuando estudiamos la glucólisis vimos
que si empezábamos con una molécula de
glucosa y si seguimos todo el proceso de
la glucólisis entonces esa glucosa que
es digamos una molécula con 6 átomos de
carbono porque digo por supuesto que
también tiene oxígeno se hidrógeno es
verdad pero en esencia es un azúcar de 6
carbonos y está se separa en dos
moléculas de piruvato verdad y cada uno
tiene 3 carbonos y en este proceso
digamos somos capaces de producir un
total de 2 atp netos verdad en realidad
tenemos una etapa de inversión donde
usamos 2 atp si obtenemos 4 atp es en la
etapa de recompensa verdad dándonos un
total de 2 atp netos de hecho voy a
escribir eso son 2 atp
netos pero no es lo único que obtuvimos
también también obtuvimos 2n además
verdad cuyo nombre completo sería
nicotina me da adenina de nucleótido y
esta molécula se reduce a n a d
muy bien y la pregunta es por qué se
reduce bueno podemos ver que esta
molécula verdad esta molécula es
positiva originalmente y llegamos a una
molécula que es neutra así que tuvo que
haber ganado electrones y por lo tanto
se redujo así que vamos a poner esto
esta molécula se redujo se redujo ahora
la pregunta es qué ocurre después de
esto y en nuestro caso digamos tuyo
varios individuos varios organismos como
nosotros digamos nuestras células
seguirán el proceso de la respiración
celular si hay suficiente oxígeno verdad
digamos las cosas prosiguen en la
mitocondria porque los piruvato si los
nh es verdad y los genes pueden
participar en la cadena de transporte de
electrones que eventualmente nos lleva a
producir más atp es verdad pero qué pasa
en la situación en la que no hay
suficiente oxígeno o simplemente digamos
si fuéramos un tipo de organismo que no
les gusta usar el oxígeno o simplemente
que no sabe cómo emplearlo entonces qué
pasaría después
pues de lo que hablaremos en este vídeo
es una posible ruta y esta posible ruta
es la fermentación láctica es la
fermentación láctica fermentación
láctica muy bien de eso es de lo que
vamos a hablar en este vídeo que es una
de las dos formas de fermentación más
importantes y la fermentación láctica no
se trata tanto de producir más a tps
sino de reciclar el piruvato y el nh que
tenemos de este lado incluso cuando
estas moléculas tienen energía libre
suficiente que pueden aportar que podría
convertirse en la atp verdad si vamos a
hacer fermentación láctica tenemos que
renunciar a lo anterior que dije para
poder usar el piruvato y oxidar el nh
entonces en este caso vamos a oxidar el
nh para obtener nuevamente tiene además
una vez que obtenemos n además entonces
podemos hacer de nuevo la glucólisis
podemos hacer que ocurra de nuevo y así
los organismos que hacen fermentación
digamos su principal fuente de energía
es la glucólisis y la fermentación es el
reciclaje de todo el material de
desperdicio
en este caso sería el piruvato y el nh
para poder contar con más n además
verdad y que pueda ocurrir de nuevo la
glucólisis y quizás aquí podrías decir
hey esto ahora suena como un poco raro
será que no lo encontramos a menudo en
los seres vivos pero probablemente cada
día o quizás cada semana consumes
organismos que realizan esta
fermentación láctica lo que tenemos en
esta imagen a la izquierda es yoghurt y
es lo que obtenemos cuando tenemos
lactobacilos digiriendo los azúcares que
se encuentran en la leche luego realizan
la glucólisis y finalmente realizan la
fermentación láctica convirtiendo el
piruvato en lactato o por ejemplo si
vemos la versión de ácido conjugado
entonces lo que se obtiene es ácido
láctico en realidad es como el piruvato
verdad del piruvato es la base conjugada
del ácido piru vico o bien podríamos
decir que el ácido piru vico es el ácido
conjugado del piruvato en nuestro caso
el lactato es la base conjugada del
ácido láctico
y esto es en esencia lo que le da el
sabor al yoghurt y aquí tengo una imagen
de una variación de los lactobacilos a
una especie de lactobacilos verdad ahora
en esta imagen que tenemos aquí si es
que a ti te gusta la comida coreana
entonces reconocerás que esto es el
kimchi verdad se usa digamos una
variación de los lactobacilos para ser
fermentación láctica en los azúcares de
las verduras ahora lo que tenemos del
lado derecho es lo que se conoce como
chucrut o también conocido digamos en
alemania como sauerkraut y nuevamente
una especie de lactobacilos realiza en
fermentación láctica en los azúcares de
la col
de hecho sauerkraut significa
literalmente col
agria así que pensemos un poquito en lo
que está ocurriendo aquí vamos a bajar a
esta parte y como lo mencioné todo esto
se trata de tomar el piruvato o el ácido
piru vico verdad esto que he dibujado
aquí es el ácido úrico déjenme anotar
esto es el ácido ácido piru vico
ubico esto es el ácido quirúrgico y esto
es digamos porque contamos con este
protón de hidrógeno que tenemos aquí
verdad lo que tengo digamos acá abajo es
exactamente lo mismo pero sin el protón
de hidrógeno aquí podemos ver que no
tenemos el protón de hidrógeno aquí el
oxígeno en este caso ha tomado el
electrón verdad aquí tenemos esto este
electrón y digamos el resto de los
hidrógenos en esta anotación distinta en
realidad están implícitos así como los
carbonos verdad estas estas líneas estas
líneas amarillas corresponden a estas de
ahí están implícitos los carbonos y cada
uno de estos y este este carbono verdad
tiene tres hidro hidrógenos que están
implícitos en esta imagen de aquí abajo
muy bien entonces lo que tengo abajo es
exactamente lo mismo sólo que si en este
protón de hidrógeno que teníamos
originalmente y entonces por eso es que
este de abajo se le conoce como piruvato
piruvato simplemente porque no tiene el
protón de hidrógeno entonces lo que
ocurriendo es que el ácido peer ubicó el
piruvato según sea el caso se utiliza
para oxidar el nh verdad va a tomar un
hidruro y tenemos al nh perdiendo
electrones y como pierde electrones
entonces decimos que se oxida aquí el nh
se oxida y así digamos tenemos n además
resultante verdad y se puede reutilizar
en la glucólisis y cuando el ácido peer
ubicó hace todo esto al nh entonces
decimos que el ácido perú vico se reduce
verdad en este caso para ir de aquí
hacia acá decimos que el ácido piru vico
se reduce voy a escribirlo bien
reduce y ya sabemos por qué se reduce se
reduce porque gana electrones y si
pensamos por ejemplo en el ácido peer
ubicó entonces lo que obtenemos del lado
derecho es ácido láctico ácido láctico y
de hecho por eso es que se le conoce a
este proceso como fermentación láctica
verdad porque uno de los productos es el
ácido láctico muy bien ahora lo primero
que quiero mostrarte porque muchas veces
en las clases de biología solo nos
enseñan que digamos está involucrado el
ine además y el nh y todo siempre parece
como si fueran moléculas abstractas
verdad pero aquí tenemos en realidad una
imagen del inea de ok aquí tenemos una
imagen del enea de esto es nicotina me
da adenina de nucleótido y aunque aquí
se ve como una molécula muy complicada
en realidad en biología es muy común ver
ciertos patrones que se repiten a menudo
por ejemplo esto esto que tenemos aquí
a esta parte de la molécula es la
nicotina me da esta parte de aquí abajo
de la molécula es nuestra vieja amiga la
adenina que vemos a menudo en el atp y
es una base nitrogenada presente en el
adn y en el rn verdad ahora bien acá
tenemos una ribosa verdad y acá tenemos
otra ribosa y acá finalmente tenemos dos
grupos fosfato entonces si nos fijamos
muy bien lo que tenemos por ejemplo aquí
abajito todo está todo está digamos
estructura que ya hemos dicho de que
está compuesta toda esa estructura es un
nucleótido mientras que toda esta
estructura de acá arriba también es un
nucleótido entonces ya podrás adivinar
por qué es le conocemos a esta molécula
como nicotina me da adenina di
nucleótido verdad ahora cobra mucho
sentido su nombre y podemos ver que en
realidad es una molécula muy complicada
no sólo se trata de ver digamos unas
letras que dicen en nea de verdad
es esta molécula resulta ser además una
coenzima y nosotros aprendimos de ellas
en otros vídeos en este caso la enzima
que cataliza esto es la lactato
deshidrogenasa muy bien déjenme subir un
poco es la lactato deshidrogenasa y
recuerda que la mayoría de las enzimas
son como son estructuras proteínicas
verdad que tienen digamos una forma más
o menos de este estilo verdad son son
estructuras proteínicas grandes que
tenemos digamos un esbozo de lo que
sería una de estas enzimas es una
estructura proteínica muy grande y luego
tenemos el nd así que déjenme poner aquí
digamos supongamos que tenemos aquí el
enea de o en el caso de la fermentación
láctica tendremos nh y simplemente estoy
tratando de hacer un esbozo de cómo se
vería definitivamente no es así en la
realidad de verdad entonces esto va a
reaccionar con el piruvato déjenme
ponerlo
con otro color acá vamos a tener el
piruvato quizás en alguna otra parte de
esta enzima verdad y al reaccionar con
el piruvato aunque podríamos considerar
al piruvato como el sustrato de esta
enzima en realidad el objetivo principal
sería oxidar el nh que pierda un
hidrógeno y un electrón extra y como
ocurre esto es bueno pues ocurre porque
tenemos este nitrógeno que tenemos aquí
verdad aquí tenemos este nitrógeno que
tiene un par de electrones solitarios
que digamos pueden lograr que se forme
un doble enlace de este lado muy bien
estos pueden moverse para formar un
doble enlace de este lado y si esto
ocurre entonces este otro doble enlace
tiene que recorrerse un sitio verdad
tiene que moverse hacia este sitio y
ahora este carbono que tendríamos aquí
verdad tiene que perder uno de estos
enlaces ya sea este o el del otro
hidrógeno verdad entonces en realidad lo
que ocurre es que suelta
todo este enlace todo este enlace lo
libera es un enlace covalente verdad y
así pierde ambos electrones luego esos
dos electrones pueden unirse por ejemplo
al carbono que tenemos arriba muy bien
este carbono ahora forma un nuevo enlace
covalente y tiene que dejar ir uno de
los enlaces covalentes que ya tenía
verdad así podría dejar a no seguir a
uno de estos que está en el enlace doble
con el oxígeno y estos electrones
entonces pueden irse al oxígeno o bien
de hecho lo que es más común pueden
usarse para atrapar un protón de
hidrógeno entonces déjenme déjenme
quitar esto a estos y vamos a dejarlo
verdad entonces estos electrones pueden
pueden atrapar un protón de hidrógeno
verdad quizás de alguna molécula de agua
que va pasando o una molécula de idron
yo verdad entonces estos pueden atrapar
algún protón de hidrógeno y entonces con
que terminamos bueno estos electrones
solitarios que teníamos en él
otro gen o verdad se mueven hacen un
doble enlace por acá que es justamente
este que tenemos del otro lado luego se
tiene que formar este nuevo doble enlace
moviendo estos electrones y forman este
doble enlace verdad y por ello hemos
perdido uno de estos dos hidrógenos
cierto entonces hemos perdido uno de
estos hidrógenos los cuales digamos ya
no he dibujado todos los hidrógenos en
el resto de esta molécula verdad
simplemente es otra anotación y entonces
tenemos de vuelta a nuestro n ade y dado
que antes nuestro nitrógeno era neutro
pero en vez de quedarse con estos dos
electrones ahora está compartiendo los
verdad entonces va a tener una carga
positiva en este caso tiene una carga
positiva y por eso le llamamos n además
verdad perdió un int
un hidrógeno con todo su electrón y
además otro electrón entonces aquí
tenemos n a d
en el de más y ahora tiene una carga
positiva por otro lado ahora si nos
fijamos en el piruvato entonces ahora
nos quedamos con lactato lo que tenemos
del lado derecho en este caso es lactato
muy bien si tuviéramos por ejemplo el
protón de aquí entonces tendríamos el
ácido láctico que es lo que teníamos acá
arriba verdad si sería contando con este
protón y bueno espero que con esto te
hayas interesado en el tema porque yo sé
que este tema es súper interesante sobre
todo por ejemplo pensar que todo esto
puede pasar en por ejemplo en los
lactobacilos verdad que son unos
organismos sumamente pequeños y por
supuesto los lactobacilos no son los
únicos que pueden hacer este proceso de
fermentación digamos pero este organismo
es muy muy útil para poder hacer todos
estos deliciosos alimentos que ya hemos
mencionado anteriormente verdad y en
particular a mí siempre me ha
maravillado que que todos estos procesos
tan complejos estén ocurriendo todo el
tiempo en la naturaleza que nos rodea
incluso
a veces ocurren en nuestro cuerpo verdad
y que de hecho puede ocurrir en estos
organismos que son tan pequeños
podríamos pensar que son muy pequeños
por ejemplo estos organismos tienen un
tamaño del orden de 5 a 10 micrómetros
de 5 a 10 micrómetros es un tamaño
sumamente pequeño es decir estamos
hablando de 5 millones y más partes de 1
metro